four days until Election Day we assess
the state of the race president Trump
goes off on an illegal immigration and
we check the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show so in honor
of Halloween we've decided to move our
entire studios to the upside down it's
very exciting
we actually are rebuilding our entire
studio we'll be massive and magnificent
and we're doing all of it with your
money which makes it even better it's
just spectacular we're gonna get to all
the news in just one second but first
let's talk about how you're gonna relax
this weekend so this weekend this whole
week and next week it's gonna be pretty
stressful right and that's why
occasionally you need to relax well one
of the best ways to relax is by getting
a massage in your own home bring the spa
to you this is where Zeile comes in
Zeile calm or zeals iPhone or Android
app ze e L calm it allows you to select
from top local licensed pre-screened
massage therapists choose your favorite
technique gender preference time and
location for your massage zeal will send
one of their 10,000 licensed massage
therapists with a massage table music
supplies they'll give you a five-star
massage I've used heal for my family my
wife has had a zeal massage my parents
of both heads deal massages my in-laws
have had it my sisters have had is just
fantastic go check it out right now
scheduling booking payment all fast and
easy even the tip is included 7 days a
week 365 days a year a zeal massage
therapist can be at your door in as
little as an hour it's privacy
convenience quality comfort that's what
you get with your massage on demand
seals been featured in The Wall Street
Journal New York Times vogue Good
Morning America and of course on this
show they are on demand again you're
bringing the spot to your house help you
get started our listeners get twenty
five bucks off their first massage with
promo code been at Cee Elcom promo code
been right now sealed calm get that
special offer when you try seal today
and for promo code Ben get twenty-five
bucks off your first in-home massage
alrighty so we are now four days from
the election it's a pro chip and suffice
it to say that nobody knows what exactly
is going on the data suggests that
Republicans could lose anywhere from
thirty to forty seats in the House and
they could pick up anywhere from zero to
five seats in the Senate but all of the
modeling is is sketchy at best the the
sort of 538 modeling suggests an eighty
five percent chance that Republicans
lose the house and a an eighty five
percent chance they retained the Senate
but we've seen those sorts of odds
bucked before
we simply don't know how turnout is
going to be reflected especially because
there is high voter enthusiasm from both
parties going in to the election now I
would say that my feeling my general
feeling is that Republican enthusiasm
was higher three weeks ago during the
Cavanaugh hearings because I've
literally never seen Republican
enthusiasm higher than it was during
that period
with that said Republican enthusiasm
remains high because the country is
simply so polarized so with that in mind
it's time to take a look at exactly what
this election is going to be like well
there's very good news for Republicans
going into the election that news is the
economic news that broke today job
growth blew past expectations in October
and year-over-year wage gains jump past
three percent for the first time since
the Great Recession according to the
Labor Department so these are this is
just a stunningly good jobs report
non-farm payrolls powered up by 250,000
jobs for the month well ahead of ref in
of estimates of 190,000 the unemployment
rate stated 3.7 percent the lowest since
December 1969 Jim Baird partner and
chief investment officer for plant Moran
financial advisors talking to CNBC he
said the job market is doing remarkably
well particularly this late in the
expansion this report adds yet another
data point to a narrative that has been
positive for the labor market this year
little seems to stand in the way of the
economy finishing 2018 out on solid
footing which would seem to cut in favor
of Republicans because obviously when
the economy is good the economy is good
we however are in the middle of an
extraordinarily polarized political
environment just finish out the news on
the economy the ranks of the unemployed
to a fresh record sorry the ranks of the
employed rose to a fresh record of a
hundred and fifty six point six million
and the employment-to-population ratio
increased to sixty point six percent
that's the highest level since December
2008 so prior to the recession that
headline jobless numbers stayed level
even amid a two-tenths of a percentage
point rise in the labor participation
rate a sixty two point nine percent this
is an unmitigated good news people
counted as outside the labor force
tumbled by four hundred eighty seven
thousand to ninety five point nine
million but wage growth is the biggest
story average hourly earnings increased
by five cents an hour for the month
eighty three cents year-over-year that's
a three point one percent gain the
annual increase in wages was the best
since 2009 it outstripped inflation so
that means a real wage growth that
number is being washed
closely by the Federal Reserve which has
been increasing its benchmark interest
rate they did it three times this year
that are on track to do it again in
December there's a lot of talk about
whether the Fed is actually tamping down
growth by essentially curtailing the
ability to lend but suffice it say that
if the economy is this strong with a
tighter fed that means that the economy
is really busting loose it's doing some
pretty amazing things and that is
largely thanks to consumer confidence
being extraordinarily high it's due to
the fact that a lot of voters and and
citizens feel that their money is not
going to be taken away with from them
with a Republican Congress and a
Republican president all this should cut
very much in favor of the Republicans
and indeed the Republicans do have a
serious shot at keeping the house even
though the odds are stacked against it's
a Shan trend
who's in elections analyst over at Real
Clear Politics has a really good piece
over there talking about what it would
take for Republicans to retain the house
here's what he says he says as we move
toward the close of this election cycle
impending control of the House of
Representatives remains up in the air
the general consensus among analysts is
that Democrats are the favorites perhaps
by a substantial margin but that
Republicans remain in the game which way
it raises a question what do we mean by
Republicans staying in the game
regardless of what the math might
indicate are there plausible scenarios
that result in the GOP keeping the house
he says yes he says there really are
believable scenarios that don't require
Republicans to win districts they've
written off Republicans have to catch
some breaks but they don't have to catch
breaks in ways that shocked and
surprised us we can still assume that
suburban districts move against them
which they almost certainly will we can
even include some surprising Democratic
wins he says in Arizona Republicans
could lose Arizona District two this
open Romney Clinton district is too much
for Republicans to hold on to in
California low Hispanic turnout enables
Republicans to hold the tenth in the
Central Valley Steve Knight squeaks out
a win in the northern reaches of La Dana
Rohrabacher keeps his seat there's a
poll today showing the Tanner
Rohrabacher is likely to keep his seat
he basically goes through state-by-state
and he says that there is indeed a
significant possibility in which
Republicans retain the house even as
they lose 22 districts to the Democrats
so he says that basically this could be
Democrats win 22 seats to Democrats win
40 seats we just don't know and that is
why you know how the president acts
right now and how the Democrats Act does
have an impact on the election so let's
talk about the the president's closing
the
his closing arguments so a lot of folks
as I said yesterday are saying why is it
why is it that Republicans don't focus
on all the good economic news and just
make their message the economy is great
and the answer is saying the economy is
good doesn't necessarily save you from
voter ire
if voters are pissed off about a
secondary issue then the economy being
excellent doesn't actually help you
remember the economic recovery of the
early 1990s began under George HW Bush
it was not enough to save him as Bill
Clinton went around railing against
George HW Bush's economy so a good
economy is not necessarily a savior and
a bad economy is definitely a killer
that's the rule about economics in
elections so what that means is that
both sides have to get their base ramped
up to ignore the economy and the
Democrats are doing this by essentially
suggesting the president Trump is a very
very mean man right this is the way that
they are doing this and President Trump
is doing this by suggesting that there
are real present threats to the United
States the Democrats are willing to
ignore so Democrats claim that Trump is
an alarmist Trump claims the Democrats
are saying what about bad things
happening to the United States both are
sort of half right and half wrong but
the Democrats have decided also that
Trump is Satan and Trump has decided
that the Democrats are completely
apathetic about bad things happening to
the country now I think that Trump is
closer to right than the Democrats are
but here is the Democrat closing
argument the Democratic closing argument
is put by Paul Krugman who has been on
this this terror recently about how
Republicans are legitimately evil so as
a piece today in The New York Times it's
called a party defined by its lines at
this point good people can't be good
Republicans well that's a pretty strong
statement
I think the good people can be good
Democrats so I'm concerned why he would
think the good people can't be good
Republicans why well you know the answer
is because of Trump right he says during
my first year as an op-ed columnist for
The New York Times I wasn't allowed to
use the word ly that first year
coincided with the 2000 election and
George W Bush was in fact being
systemically dishonest about his
economic proposals saying false things
about who would benefit from his tax cut
and the implications of Social Security
privatization but the notion that a
major party's presidential candidate
would go beyond spent outright lies
seemed to out seem dangerous and saying
it was considered beyond the pale
obviously that prohibition no longer
holds on this opinion page suffice it to
say but the opinion pages of the newer
times were better when Democrats like
Paul Krugman couldn't overuse the word
I to label anything that they think is a
misinterpretation he says at this point
the gops campaign message consisted of
nothing but lies yeah that's not an
overstatement it's hard to think of a
single true thing Republicans are
running on really is it that hard to
think of a single true thing how about
the economy how about the fact that
Obamacare has been a failure how about
the fact that we do in fact need to
secure our borders how about the fact
that we do need to build up our military
there are a lot of things Republicans
run on that are not in fact lies what
are the big lies well here's what
Krugman says he says it's a Republican
problem and it's not just Donald Trump
but he really means it's just Donald
Trump and his Republicans Democrats
aren't Saints but they campaign mostly
on real issues
really they've been campaigning on
transgender bathrooms
they've been campaigning on we should
let everybody through the border because
Donald Trump is mean they've been
campaigning on Russia collusion those
are all real issues all right says
Democrats aren't Saints but they
campaign mostly unreal issues and
generally do in fact stand for more or
less what they claim to stand for as
well see this is not in fact true he
says Republicans don't and the total
dishonesty of Republican electioneering
should itself be a decisive political
issue because at this point it defines
the party's character what are
Republicans lying about as I said almost
everything thank you thanks Paul says
but there are two big teams they lie
about their agenda pretending their
policies would help the middle and
working classes when they would in fact
do the opposite um did he see the
economic report today in which job
growth was massive and wage growth was
massive like that helps the poor and
working-class actually when the economy
is good he says and they lie about the
problems America faces hyping an
imaginary threat from scary dark-skinned
people and increasingly attributing that
threat to Jewish conspirators okay that
last part is just a while public uns are
not going around attributing the threat
to the United States to quote-unquote
Jewish conspirators they're saying that
George Soros funds bad people that is
absolutely true that does not mean it's
an anti-semitic riff any more than it's
anti-semitic for the Democrats to claim
that Sheldon Adelson funds a lot of
Republican causes which is also true as
opposed and his statement hyping an
imaginary threat from scary dark-skinned
people see this is what I was saying
yesterday the Democrats have fallen
right into Trump's trap because Trump
says we've got a crisis on a southern
border Democrats instead of saying we do
have a problem
with our southern border and we need to
solve that but it's not a crisis instead
of saying that they go to there's no
crisis at all everything's hunky-dory
and you're just saying that cuz you're
racist to which the Republican responses
go after yourself yeah I'd say that
there's a threat and you say that I'm a
racist for saying there's a threat and
we'll go through the rest of Paul
Krugman's column because this is
basically the Democratic closing
argument and then we'll get to how
President Trump is fighting back against
that I also want to make a couple of
comments about his statement the
Democrats are telling the truth about
their agenda as we will see this is
eminently untrue but first let's talk
about how you can pay off those credit
card bills so let's be real credit cards
have been telling us for a long time
credit card companies that you should
buy now and pay it later but the problem
is that those interest rates skyrocket
which is why you should be consolidating
your debt and paying off your credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
with Lending Club since 2007 Lending
Club has helped millions of people
regain control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards all you have to do is go to
Lending Club com you tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number-one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Ben you can
check in rate minutes power up to 40
grand
that's Lending Club com / Bennigan's
Lending Club com / ban all loans made by
web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender yeah there are a lot of reasons
you might need a quick swing loan at a
decent rate that's where Lending Club
comes in again you can check that right
minutes and you can borrow up to $40,000
so if you've racked up credit card bills
then it's absolutely imperative to go
check out Lending Club Lending Club com
/ Ben go check it out right now
okay so paul krugman of the new york
times continues he says while
republicans truly stand for and have for
decades is cutting taxes on the rich and
slashing social programs sure enough
last year they succeeded in ramming
through a huge tax cut a mainly at
corporations in the wealthy and came
within one vote of passing a health
reform that according to the CBO would
have caused 32 million Americans to lose
health coverage well no that is not what
the CBO report actually said what CBO
report actually said is that a bunch of
people who had individual plans before
and now have to be covered by Obamacare
would no longer have Obamacare and
presumably go back to individual plans
so that is not actually what the CBO
said he says selling racial fear
was easier in the early 1980s and 1990s
when America really was suffering from
high levels of in our Senate crime since
then violent crime has plunged what's a
fear monger to do the answer is lie and
here's where Krugman gets to the center
of his of his contention that only bad
people can vote Republican the lies have
come non-stop since Trump's inauguration
address which conveyed a false vision of
American carnage but they've gotten ever
more extreme culminating the portrayal
of a small caravan of refugees still a
thousand miles from the border as an
imminent menacing invasion somehow full
of diseased Middle Eastern terrorists
now as I've said so I think that the
threat of the caravan is exaggerated I
do because last time there was a caravan
by the time it reached the United States
border was like 200 people and they
showed up asking for asylum and a Border
Patrol station and then they were
processed and most of them were sent
back so is this an existential threat to
the security of the United States no I
don't think the caravan is but is it is
symbolic and it is obviously symbolic
and the fact that Democrats refused to
acknowledge the symbolism of the caravan
the fact that Democrats refused to
acknowledge that is a stands in for the
broader issue of people crossing the
border illegally without permission of
the US government making themselves at
home sometimes having criminal
backgrounds that's why Democrats are not
resonating with the American people on
this issue and Krugman says there's an
adman insinuation that sinister Jewish
financiers are the real culprits behind
this invasion well no it turns out the
demonizing George Soros is not
anti-semitic demonizing George Soros may
be bad but there's a difference between
bad and inflammatory and anti-semitic he
says those who remain in the Republican
Party are either fanatics willing to do
anything in pursuit of power or cynics
willing to go along with anything for a
share of the Spoils or possibly a bunch
of people who don't want anyone like
Paul Krugman anywhere near the levers of
power because the Democrats have shown
themselves to be utterly irresponsible
people like Paul Krugman are completely
wild they have not posited either
anything remotely approaching a moderate
policy or even a moderate rhetoric I
mean Paul Krugman is literally sitting
there labeling 60 million Americans bad
human beings because they're voting the
way he doesn't want them to vote he says
what will this party do if it retains
full control of Congress next week what
we've seen over and over again is that
for these people there are no limits no
bottom if they pull this midterm
election out expect the worst of the
worst be Paul Krugman would the worst be
like the Holocaust like well you want to
specify of course he's not going to
because
this is a scare tactic in and of itself
so it's so funny to hear the Democrats
saying Trump engages in the politics of
fear as they suggest that half of
Americans are evil human beings for
voting the way they don't want which is
indeed engaging in the politics of fear
now it is true that both sides are
engaging in the politics of fear the
question is which fear is more justified
so president Trump yesterday gave a
speech in the White House in which he
talked about the military response to
the caravan now is it necessary to send
15,000 troops the size of the
Afghanistan surge down to the border of
Mexico no I don't think that
logistically speaking that is necessary
to deal with a caravan that is dwindling
by the day with that said should we
secure our border of course we should
secure our border and the president is
using language being tough on
immigration that is obviously directed
toward the election again directed at
reminding Americans the Democrats don't
take this issue particularly seriously
and he wins every time
they declare that he's a white
supremacist because here's how the logic
goes Trump says listen we got a crisis
at the border and Democrats say you're a
racist for saying so and he says okay so
you only want to acknowledge that
there's a problem they say you're a
racist for exaggerating the problem if
you just keep shouting racist and over
and over and over while the American
people look at a caravan of illegal
immigrants coming through Mexico in some
cases you can see there are tapes of
people in the caravan I'm sure a lot of
people in caravan are fine folks who
just want a better economic life there
are some people in the caravan there's
video of it Benny Johnson has it up at
Daily Caller
there's video of some of the members of
the caravan throwing rocks and members
of police I mean those are not people we
need in the United States okay but
President Trump is obviously ginning up
the base for the election is it right I
don't think it's right to exaggerate is
it politically effective yeah it
probably is politically effective here's
President Trump yesterday talking about
what he's told the military to do in the
case of people who are throwing rocks
but I will tell you this anybody
throwing stones rocks like they did to
Mexico and the Mexican military of
Mexican place where they badly hurt
police and soldiers of Mexico we will
consider that a firearm because there's
not much difference when you get hit in
the face with a rock which as you know
there was very violent a few days ago
very very violent okay so people of
course saying
Trump now says that if you throw a rock
at the border police that they're gonna
shoot you to death okay that's not what
he's really saying there okay and nobody
in the military is gonna obey that order
he's saying if you feel that your life
is in danger you can you can in use
rules of engagement that allow you to
defend yourself with a firearm right
which is basically what every civilized
country would do Trump just puts it in
the most brutal way so people react in
the most overall way and then Trump says
listen migrants who wants asylum can
show up at a port of entry but if they
show up between the borders we are
deporting them instead migrants seeking
asylum will have to present themselves
lawfully at a port of entry so they are
going to have to lawfully present
themselves at a port of entry which
presumably is what they're going to do I
mean that's exactly what the migrant did
a couple of the migrants did a couple of
years ago
the problem for the Democrats is that
they react with outsized outrage at
everything president from does and Trump
is trolling them engages politically
speaking president Trump is obviously
trolling them but the Democrats react by
saying that anything Trump says about
immigration is just due to racism which
again alienates a huge swath of the
American public that is concerned about
illegal immigration may not even love
president Trump's exaggerations but if
they have to choose between Trump's
exaggerations and and his sort of
maligning of broader groups and a
Democratic Party that assumes that any
any talk about this issue is endemically
racist they're gonna choose from a Trump
understands it's binary the Democrats
think it's binary too but if they think
they're gonna win on the basis of
calling people racist they are wrong
here are some own Sanders and CNN
suggesting that you know president
Trump's remarks are a defense of white
supremacy you know I hope when the White
House sent out those statements today
the remarks with the president they
titled live in defense of white
supremacy because that's exactly what I
heard from the white from the White
House which is unfortunate look if we
want to we want to have a conversation
about fixing our fighting it's not these
brown people are coming to take your
jobs they're criminals we can't trust
them we're gonna shoot him at the border
and the Democrats are going to come in
so you need to buffer the report here's
what I okay well she's adding me Brown
people section of that he's saying there
are people who are coming into the
United States who may be criminals there
are people coming into the United States
we have embedded there are people coming
into the United States we're going to
undercut our labor base you
used to say that's where to stuff Bernie
Sanders you know who else used to say
that sort of stuff Harry Reid it's not
racist just because you are talking
about a group of people coming up from a
place where people have brown skin
presumably if there are a bunch of
people coming from Canada throwing rocks
at police officer as well while carrying
the Canadian flag and trying to cross
the border
Trump would react similarly that's not
going to happen because Canada is
actually not a country where people are
desperate to leave it is happening from
Central and Latin America because those
are countries where people are desperate
to leave that's just a fact and now
we're going to talk about the media's
response and again Paul Krugman suggests
that over the New York Times the
Democrats are telling the truth about
their agenda will show that is certainly
not the case in just one second first
let's talk about the best coffee on the
market in the midst of all the whining
coming from the left on a variety of
topics the suggestion that every
Republican is evil the suggestion that
free speech needs to be curbed in
certain ways in order to make room for
feelings you have to wonder why would
anybody act this way well my guess is
they're not getting their daily dose of
black rifle coffee because black rifle
coffee is the best coffee on the market
it is so good not only is the coffee
fantastic
the founders of black rifle coffee these
are folks with conservative values a pro
veteran mission black rifle coffee is
roasted order it guarantees you fresh
delicious coffee with every order and
black rifle coffee gives a portion of
their sales to vets and first responder
causes black rifles coffee club makes
things easy just pick your blend and the
amount you want black rifle ships your
coffee right to your door every month
hassle free nothing cares a bad attitude
quite like starting your day with the
most American coffee in America black
rifle coffee visit black rifle coffee
calm slash Bend and you get 15% off your
order that's black rifle coffee calm
slash pen for 15% off go check it out
right now black rifle coffee calm slash
pen again fifteen percent off your order
also you're helping a company founded by
that's a great great company go check it
out right now black rifle coffee calm
slash Ben so the media are so upset
about Trump they don't even want to play
then anyone play his ads we talked
yesterday about an ad that president
Trump put out that showed a guy named
Braco Montez who was an illegal
immigrant who entered the United States
a couple of different times once under
Clinton once under Bush remained under
Obama killed a couple of police officers
and Trump linked that to the illegal
immigrant migrant Caravan that is coming
up from the south and people immediately
- racist here's wolf blitzer an
objective journalist being objectively
journalism ik right suggesting that he
doesn't even want to play the ad it's
just so terrible I can't even plan I
just can't I can't play it I mean it's
just that bad it's just everything's
terrible you look at the the rest of the
video and I don't even play it and get
free advertising - to those out there
but if you look at the rest of it do you
see hordes of invaders coming in -
threatening to come into the United
States tearing down walls and fences and
threatening the American people it's
really pretty awful really it's totally
ok except that the fact is that we don't
know who the migrants are who are coming
up and well I say that I think that the
ad is alarmist and I do think the ad is
alarmist the suggestion it's so awful
you can't even play it is just it's a
bizarre contention again these are folks
who are fully willing to play every ad
coming from Democrats suggesting that
Republicans were going to deprive
millions of people of their health care
and leave them to die that was totally
ok but Trump saying we may have a
problem with illegal immigration and
then exaggerating that case for
political effect that's unplayable
Valerie Jarrett says this ad is sad
political fear-mongering it's just
fear-mongering so this is the new
democratic by ward these days the
Republicans are engaged in
fear-mongering
welcome to politics gang look it's just
a sad page from an old playbook called
political fear-mongering 101 we've seen
it used time and time and time again
it's designed to scare people and to
motivate them to not focus on the issues
that are really important to distract
them from issues that as I travel around
the country I hear about from everyday
Americans issue okay if you're actually
hearing the issues that everyday
Americans care about they do care about
illegal immigration they do care about
the economy again Democrats suggesting
they are on their high horse about
fear-mongering is it's just astonishing
there's there's a really good post by
noah rothman over at commentary magazine
in which he goes through this he says
the washington post declared that Trump
and the GOP have settled on fear and
falsehoods as a closing argument with a
little racially tinged rhetoric as a
topper he says on health care and
entitlements the report noted the GOP
has shown a willingness to instill fear
in their electorate you see Republican
lawmakers are suddenly supportive of
protections for pre-existing conditions
despite their opposition's to the ACA
and then he goes on to talk about all of
the supposed Republican fear-mongering
and he says he's armed
have a point Donald Trump's attempts to
suggest that radical Islamist terrorists
from the Middle East had infiltrated a
caravan of asylum seekers traveling
north through Mexico from Honduras is
fear-mongering The Times is on solid
ground wouldn't impugns efforts by
Republican candidates to cast Antonio
Delgado a Rhodes Scholar who toyed with
the career of music as a big-city rapper
and just as all these articles note
election-year efforts by the incumbent
party to stoke baseless fears is a
pretty standard tactic and yet you would
have be hard-pressed to find such
ubiquitous denunciations of democratic
efforts to instill in the minds of
voters and your existential fear of the
GOP and then he just lists off all of
these fear tactics used by Democrats in
2010 Republicans were admonished for
circulating RNC approved documents that
label President Obama a socialist the
GOP candidates were scolded for
criticizing Barack Obama's support for
the construction of a mosque near Ground
Zero in Manhattan
ABC News savage Republican candidates
who attacks Democrats for supporting
programs they outsource American jobs
and exported American capital to China a
party with its back against the wall
routinely resorts to fear tactics for
much of the last decade that was the
Democratic Party the agenda projects
accused the GOP of wanting to eliminate
Medicare in 2011 and they Illustrated
that by showing Paul Ryan tossing an
elderly woman off a cliff in 2002 in
2012 sorry Vice President Joe Biden
accused the GOP of seeking to
reinstitute black slavery senator Bernie
Sanders said Republicans sought the
elimination of the Department of
Veterans Affairs and Social Security in
2013 DNC chairman chairwoman debbie
Wasserman Schultz summarized the
Republican platform as let's pick women
and immigrants out of the country in
2015 Hillary Clinton followed suit
claiming that Ted Cruz had tried to ban
contraception okay so all of the
fear-mongering
welcome to American politics where this
sort of stuff happens all the time and
it does raise a severe question for the
Democrats that they don't want to deal
with and this is why they're going to
simply shout racist what would you do
with this caravan of migrants what would
you do with folks who are seeking asylum
and are coming here not because they
actually are being targeted by any sort
of political violence but because
they're looking for more economic
opportunity and don't have any intention
of assimilating what would you do with
those people well the answer for
Democrats is they won't answer the
question or the lie about it so just
today a group of care event migrants
from Honduras filed a class action
lawsuit against
Trump and various government agencies
including Homeland Security for
violating their Fifth Amendment due
process rights if the government turns
the caravan away as Trump has signaled
he intends to do the lawsuit was filed
by 1200 nationals and it maintains that
since the migrants are coming from three
countries Guatemala Honduras and El
Salvador suffering human rights crises
some migrants have grounds for admission
as asylum seekers by turning them away
without fully hearing their asylum
claims they contend the president and
his administration are infringing upon
their rights under the Administrative
Procedures Act and the declaratory
judgment Act thus according to James
Barrett over a Daily wire but the
Constitution applies to those living
legally in the US legal precedent has
applied due process to aliens and
deportation proceedings so the lawsuit
Democrats are gonna have to answer do
they think that these folks should be
able to sue their way into the United
States Democrats are also gonna have to
answer questions about their own
treatment of people who have sought
asylum in the United States and crossed
the border in order to do so James
O'Keefe Project Veritas released an
undercover sting video on Thursday night
appearing to show campaign staffers for
beta O'Rourke quote illegally using
campaign resources to buy supplies and
help transport hunter and aliens now
listen you want to help folks who are
already across the border in the United
States and they are here pending an
asylum claim that's legal there are
folks who do it but misappropriating
campaign resources in order to do that
that is illegal and apparently that was
happening over a Bader Ulrich's campaign
and then they wonder why so many
Americans are not resounding to the
Democratic take on illegal immigration
and this is why when Paul Krugman says
that Democrats are being honest about
their agenda no they are not James
O'Keefe has almost single-handedly
unmasked the Democrats for just how
dishonest they are but just by speaking
to members of their own campaign there's
a little bit of the tape when O'Keefe's
folks over a project ferret house went
into the beta O'Rourke headquarters and
started asking around about whether the
funds for beta O'Rourke were being used
to help out Honduran
caravan the caravan folks
[Music]
so you know obviously better work not
exactly being forthcoming about his own
politics and then there's Andrew Gilliam
so Andrew Gilliam over in Florida who's
being given the royal treatment by the
media Andrew gillum's own staffers are
saying that he is the craziest of the
craziest this is omar smith a Gilliam
campaign staffer saying that this guy is
basically a radical so you have the
extreme right wingers those are the the
Trump and the crazy crazy crazy crazy
Republicans the progressives are the
crazy crazy crazy Democrat are you not a
progressing isn't killing a progressive
you let me the progressive so Gilliam is
part of the crazy crazy so he is part of
the crazy crazy creepy okay and that is
absolutely true
everybody knows the end regale him as
part of the crazy crazy he's been trying
to label Ron de santis who they're both
running for governor of Florida right
now he's been trying to label Ron de
santis a racist that is such nonsense
there is no evidence that Ron de Santa
sees a racist he tried to label him an
anti-semite which is absurd Ron de
santis I know representative the census
that is a bunch of crap it is just not
true in any conceivable way and not only
that Andrew Gilliam like that guy's
gonna call Ron de santis you know a
racist in anti-semite Andrew Gilliam it
has been connected with a wide variety
of groups that promote boycott
divestment and sanctions against Israel
okay which would destroyed the State of
Israel if it were adopted Gilliam has
ignored growing calls to disavow this
group with which is associated dream
defenders even as the largest Jewish
weekly publication in the country the
Jewish pressed urged Florida's Jewish
residents to vote for DeSantis dream
defenders and Gilliam have an extensive
history he recently signed the group's
freedom pledge promising not to accept
money from private persons by signing
the pledge he endorsed the group's
radical freedom papers that decry police
and prisons as
if that's the actual Democratic Party so
Paul Krugman says Republicans are hiding
their agenda no Democrats are hiding
their agenda a lot more n they're hiding
their corruption - hey Andrew Gilliam is
deeply corrupt by every available
indicator any Republican who had the
kind of corruption record Andrew Gilliam
has would not survive an election cycle
really it's it's at least not at the
gubernatorial level well we'll talk
about that in just a second but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire calm and subscribe when you do
$9.99 a month you get my show you get
the rest of Clavin show you get the rest
of Noel's a show and coming up Tuesday
November 6th we have our daily wire
backstage election edition we will be
here drinking ourselves to death in good
humor or out of just absolute rage and
horror God King Jeremy boring me Andrew
Clavin the terrible Michel Noel's Alicia
Kraus and for some reason Colton Hass
will be covering all the latest election
news as it happens our own Cassie Dillon
and Colton Haas will be bringing us
updates from Twitter to make sure to
tune in as always only daily where
subscribers get to ask the questions so
make sure to subscribe today also don't
miss Andrew Clayton's next chapter of
another Kingdom performed by the
execrable Michael Knowles today we'll be
live-streaming the first 15 minutes of
episode 5 which is titled the nightmare
feast which might also be our election
special we'll come to think of it it
really depends on how that actually goes
so we will go check that out also make
sure that you subscribe over at YouTube
iTunes please leave us a review sunday
special this week at tucker carlson it's
awesome it's really really good you're
gonna want to see it is I think it's one
of the best we've ever done
so go check that out right now for $99 a
year by the way you got the annual
subscription all of those myriad glories
Plus this reactivated the leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr see every time I'm
back in LA just poof reactivates that's
the magic of the leftist here's hot or
cold tumblr go check that out right now
the only problem is that in order for me
to find it I had to come into this deep
dank place this this studio that
apparently as Colton suggested was a
former laser tag facility where we were
filming for the next few weeks but in
any case go subscribe it'll help us pay
for the studio renovation that must be
done obviously go check that out right
now we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk about Andrew gillum's
campaign for just a second so the dude
has an FBI problem and the mainstream
media have been ignoring it like really
ignoring it in a major way imagine that
a Republican candidate we're basically
implica lis been implicated in an FBI
sting scheme to give them a bunch of
goodies they accepted a bunch of goodies
from an FBI undercover agent and in
return for favors to be done on public
private works hey that might be a
front-page story well that's pretty much
what's happened with Andrew Gilliam and
the Tampa Bay Times is covered it but
it's not being widely covered in the
mainstream kind of national media here's
what the Tempah Bay Times says starting
in 2015 FBI agents came to Tallahassee
he was the mayor of Tallahassee posing
as businessman considering investments
in the city the three men who reportedly
identified themselves as Mike sweets
Mike Miller and Brian Butler spent
months cozying up to city officials and
people close to them the FBI
investigation based in part on their
undercover work has yielded several
rounds of subpoenas but no charges as of
yet a slew of Tallahassee officials and
insiders have been named in those
subpoenas over the past year in 2013 the
Community Redevelopment Agency Intelli
Hasse voted to give 1.3 million dollars
in taxpayer money to help a particularly
lobbyist named Adam quarry who's a
longtime at Gilliam friend and Ally
until Gilliam cut ties with him when he
became inconvenient Gilliam voted with
the rest of his fellow city
commissioners to fund the project at the
time hilum's vote raised eyebrows
because of his close association with
Cory one year later Cory served as
treasurer of gillum's mayoral campaign
it also turns out that the FBI was
giving all sorts of goodies to kill him
and his friends ok so there's an ethics
board that's been checking this out
according to according to the newspapers
Cory became close with Miller reportedly
introducing Gilliam to an undercover
agent sometime in 2016 one of the
reported meetings between Cory Gilliam
and Miller Miller being the FBI agent at
the Edison in May of that year became a
point of controversy when the Democrat
is the the local newspaper this how has
a Democrat reported that Corey scheduled
the meeting while on vacation with
Gilliam and other city lobbyists in
Costa Rica so now they're checking out
what's the deal with Costa Rica right
that's a violation of ethics okay go
home says he did not discuss business in
Costa Rica it was just to make vacation
with
long time friends McQuarrie's attorney
has maintained Gilliam never reimbursed
the lobbyists for his portion of the
trip also under investigation Gilliam
took a trip with his brothers Marcus
Cory and Miller to New York in August
2016 in an email inviting gillip to meet
up in New York
Cory noted that Miller had arranged
hotel rooms and outing to a Mets game
and a boat trip to the Statue of Liberty
the group didn't go to the Mets game but
they did get free tickets to Hamilton
Gilliam says he didn't allow the FBI
agents to pay for any part of his trip
to New York but the texts released by
his chief lobbyist attorney showed the
undercover agent paid for the Hamilton
tickets so bottom line is that
theoretically this FBI agents listen to
help from a lobbyist who proceeded to
allow payoffs to go through to Gilliam
who then helped vote for this project
that helped the lobbyist right that's
that's the basic scheme here and the
mainstream media are basically ignoring
all that I have to ask why it is that
Andrew Gilliam is getting the sort of
attention when John James the republican
senatorial candidate in Michigan who's a
black a black former Air Force pilot is
he's getting very little attention
running a very competitive race in a
purple state in Michigan and the answer
has to be the de media love Andrew
Gilliam because Andrew Gilliam is a
future Barack Obama in their view he is
very radical in his politics
so when Democrats tell you they are not
lying about their own agenda that is
simply not true they are in fact lying
about their agenda on a fairly regular
basis and when they are honest about it
it doesn't go well for them so John
tester who's senator from Montana he was
asked about gun control he basically
admits it doesn't even work and he wants
it anyway this is how radical Democrats
are here's what he said he was asked in
June about all of this he said that gun
control would not stop school shootings
but it's going to help okay so this is
the way the Democrats push they push
their policies regardless as to whether
those policies are actually effective or
not okay so let's do a little bit of
mail bagging because it is indeed day
Friday so let's jump in Troy says hi Ben
love the show would you be surprised if
Republicans maintained control of the
house if they do who would you want is
next speaker Jim Jordan seems like a
good choice I really like representative
Jordan I think that he was falsely
maligned by the press I don't see any
reason Jim Jordan wouldn't make an
excellent Speaker of the House I'm not
opposed to Kevin McCarthy is Speaker of
the House even though there's been a lot
of talk about him being too squishy the
fact is that Kevin McCarthy
is less squishy I think on some of these
issues then for example Paul Ryan has
been you might be able to build more
coalition's then Jim Jordan Jim Jordan
will be harder to line if I had to
choose between the two I would choose
Jim Jordan Lee says dear mr. Shapiro
ever since we're examining my political
beliefs I find it difficult to get
myself into dating since I'm concerned
girls will immediately write me off
because of my views I'm not a trump
supporter nor conservative though I'm
central right and don't buy into a lot
of social propaganda I'm personally not
that judgmental of people's views unless
they're extreme but I feel it makes it
difficult to be forthcoming with how I
see things do you have any advice on how
to handle this concern well it depends I
mean if you are dating for marriage
then you obviously need to put your
values at the center of your dating life
and that means discussing issues of deep
concern to you and how you want to raise
your kids if you're just dating for
quote-unquote fun if you're doing that
then you presumably you do what
everybody else does when they're dating
for fun which is you hide your crazy
until a little bit later in the
relationship I don't think that you
necessarily lead with your most extreme
positions when you're talking with
somebody you want to date but you should
make clear that you are of conservative
political bent that you have certain
central values that you think are
important to you and then you have
conversations about those values like
when I started dating my wife our first
our very first date was a three-hour
date in which we discussed free will and
determinism and talked about sort of
central values we didn't talk a lot of
politics per se we were talking sort of
deeper levels than that but I also knew
that my wife was Orthodox right in my
wife or the northen oxq so we already
had certain central values in common
which is why I think that dating folks
within your religious tradition is a
very good idea as a general rule you
know when it came to politics my wife
used to be I think a lot more moderate
on politics so I remember one of our
first dates we talked about the death
penalty and gun control she was more pro
gun control at that time she was also
more skeptical of death penalty than I
was but we were able to discuss those
things and she didn't think it was crazy
that I was anti gun control and she
didn't think it was crazy that I was
that I was in favor of the death penalty
we were able to talk all of those things
through so the real question is can you
talk those things through or are you
dealing with somebody who is going to
throw you out because you disagree on
these issues and is non malleable on
these issues maybe you'll be changed by
her opinions but you should at least be
able to have the conversation if you
can't it's know that Edward says hey bud
this week one of my poli-sci professors
extensively about Republicans and their
disgraceful Southern Strategy as if it
were established fact it seems like this
line of thinking has been taught for so
long it just seems to pass as accepted
wisdom how do you rebut these claims
what really happened in the south to
flip it from blue to red and why exactly
do folks on the Left still insinuate
that the south is full of racist white
men who had immediately turned back to
slavery if given the chance thanks love
the show well the last part is really
the question because the truth is that
as the Democrat as the constituency in
the south got younger it got more
Republican so as the south got less
racist it also got more Republican their
regional polls from pew showing that all
of the kind of malign talk about people
from the south being more racist than
people from other parts of the country
is just not true
racism is fairly equivalent to all the
way across the country not only that if
you look historically the Republicans
didn't actually take the south in terms
of the House of Representatives and so
basically 1994 so if it was the 1968
Southern Strategy that shifted
everything then why did it take until
1994 for Republicans to take the house
the the trends are just not strong
enough to suggest that race alone is
what shifted all this now was there a
southern strategy that was used by the
Nixon campaign well some members of that
campaign have suggested that there was
and they've basically admitted that were
their racial strategies used by
Democrats at the same time sure George
Wallace was a Democrat and the vast
majority of people who voted racist
continued to vote Democrat okay so that
this this note this notion that the
Southern Strategy is what completely
changed the the facts on the ground is
similar it's just not true it's just not
it does not happen to be true so there
is a a great piece by Dan mcLaughlin
from about 2012 called the Southern
Strategy myth and the lost majority and
it basically suggests that this stuff is
exaggerated so it was you know look we
can go through this a little bit so here
let me go through a little bit first
according to professors Richard Johnston
of the University of Pennsylvania and
Byron Schaefer of the University of
Wisconsin the shift in the south from
Democratic to Republican was
overwhelmingly a question not of race
but of economic growth the movement
toward republicanism in the south began
in the 1950s
well the Eisenhower administration was
forcibly desegregating schools as the
south industrialized working class
whites and blacks remained Democrats
until the 1990s here's the New York
Times reporting on this quote to give
one example
in the 50s among southerners in
low-income tercile 43% voted for
Republican presidential candidates in
the high-income Tercel 53% voted
Republican by the 1980s those figures
were 51% and 77% wealthy southerners
shifted rightward in droves poorer ones
did not sure on trend of
RealClearPolitics degrees
he says the GOP gradually increased its
support in the south from 1928 to 2010
and Tim McLaughlin says as late as 2010
there were still states like Alabama in
North Carolina that were voting in their
first Republican legislative majority
since reconstruction something that
would have happened overnight in the
late 60s if the partisan realignment had
been driven by lockstep white voting
loyalties along racial lines so that's
the the data just are not there to
support the idea that the entire south
shifted Republican because of the race
issue wasn't one of many issues yes was
it was it the key issue or even a key
issue probably not probably not okay a
couple more of these let's see Jesse
what are your thoughts on conservative
think-tanks left obviously is willing to
distort science to fit whatever that
ideology is at the moment and I think
it's important to have institutions that
are some that are somewhat protected
from the result personally I love
crunching numbers and analyzing data so
I also wonder how one goes about working
at a think-tank thanks for all you do
well you get internships at places like
Heritage Foundation or AEI
I have friends I have relatives who have
done that I think that it is it is
important for these institutions to be
there I get a lot of my data from think
tanks on both left and right in fact
there are people who spend their day
actually diving into the numbers and the
data is deeply helpful I'm a big fan
Santino's has had been I have a debate
coming up against my University's
Democrat Club and I've been dealt the
topic of health care what prominent
figure on the left in your opinion holds
the most substantial solid perspective
on health care essentially who Shapiro
on the Left I can listen to in regards
to health care to better prepare myself
Thanks well I believe that there's
animat breunig who is a big advocate of
sort of Nordic socialism in order to
democratic socialism
there's democratic socialism has a
capitalist route and he talked about
health care fairly regularly the truth
is that there the the spectrum of health
care thought is not quite broken down
along left/right like avec Roy he's a
really good health care analyst and he
tends to be more right leaning on some
things and more left leaning on others
he's kind of moderate
Ezekiel Emanuel who was one of the
creators of Obamacare
has written extensively
about these topics there they're a bunch
of studies out there that are worth
noting by the way on healthcare and
American healthcare in particular some
fibs that have been put out there number
one the fib that the u.s. spends grossly
more per capita GDP on health care than
any other country we also make grossly
more money if you actually were to chart
a line among industrialized countries as
to income versus healthcare spending
what you see is basically a straight
straight arithmetic relationship meaning
that as GDP increases per capita so does
health care spending and the United
States is basically right along that
line we're not wildly overspending on
health care the the other point to be
made is that when people talk about life
expectancy in the United States is low
for spending this much money well not
when you remove car accidents and
murders both of which we have
disproportionately here in the United
States and neither of which reflects on
the US healthcare system right all of
that just reflects on people dying
prematurely for reasons having nothing
to do with health care so those are a
couple of facts that you should have in
your back pocket I would recommend
there's a good book called mortal peril
by Richard Epstein all about the
quote/unquote right to health care
that's worth reading and they're they're
a bunch of good sources on health care
that are they're worth checking out
Mitchell says Ben I recently decided to
go back to school for the green
engineering being 30 and back in college
I have a different look on things than
my peers needing to take a college
writing course we were presented with
our final project this week where to
choose a topic pertaining to the
workforce and create a persuasive
research paper regarding our topic I
informed my instructor I intend to
research why the gender pay gap is a
myth this did not go over well a few of
the students and the instructor became
very unhappy that I could even think
such a thing I was then told that in the
spirit of the project I would not be
allowed to continue with the topic
because it is considered too offensive
so my question is if this is supposed to
be a persuasive paper wouldn't this fit
the criteria and what makes this
offensive also the only thing I can
think of is they believe I'm attacking
their victimhood any advice on another
topic I could do well I mean dude you
knew when you said that that you were
slapping them right in the face I mean
obviously if you had just said listen I
want to research the pay gap and then
come to the conclusion the pay gap may
be a myth
then maybe they'd let get away with it
but yeah obviously there's nothing
sexist or offensive about the idea of
the pay gap is a myth the pay gap is a
myth by all available data so that is
just again these people taking offense
at fact I just did a speech in British
Columbia at the University of British
Columbia in which I began the speech by
saying facts are not offensive and then
I just
read basically a list of fact and people
got offended because that's what happens
when you say things that are factual
that people do not like unfortunately so
you know as far as other topics that you
could do you know I think that there are
a lot of topics that you could do but if
you want one that's not going to offend
people all that much then you're gonna
have to pick something that is that is
outside the realm of the quote-unquote
offensive you might do one on where you
think that it is necessary for the
United States to start thinking about
global warming for example because
that's more of a nuance to topic the
current Nobel Prize winners have some
great papers on that particular topic it
cuts against a lot of leftist
preconceptions you go back and listen to
our show a couple of weeks ago we talked
about it okay time for some things I
like and some things that I hate so this
entire week because of the Pittsburgh
shooting we've been doing Jewish new
gunam meaning Jewish tunes that are used
in prayer a lot this one is a very
famous one it's actually a an old Hebrew
lullaby and it comes from the book of
Genesis in the portion when Jacob's
giving a blessing to Menachem and and a
fryin and the sons of Joseph and the the
text of it talks about the angel that
protects me that angel should protect
you and allow you to prosper in the Land
of Israel here is a little bit of that
tune I use it pretty frequently I tend
to I do kazama's for the minions so very
often I'm asked to kind of pray for the
for the group on on Sabbath particularly
the tune I really like using so here's a
little bit of that tune
[Music]
[Applause]
he called
[Music]
it's very nice to me and with the palsy
bounnam that I've been playing this week
days they're the tunes are adaptable to
various kind of biblical texts this one
as I say is from Genesis 4816 this made
the angel who hath redeemed me from all
evil bless the lads and let my name be
named in them and in the name of my
father's Abraham and Isaac and let them
grow into a multitude in the midst of
the earth so that's the that's the basic
translation okay time for a quick thing
that I hate okay so this is pretty
spectacular apparently an actor who has
appeared on the television shows better
call Saul and Longmire admitted to a
local news outlet on Monday he severed
his arm and lied about how it happened
by posing as a war veteran so table
tourette is an Albuquerque New Mexico
based actor he said he'd been diagnosed
with bipolar disorder and that he sawed
off his arm during a psychotic episode
17 years ago first of all I don't know
if he was mentally disordered maybe he
just felt that he was a two-armed / a
one-armed person in a two-armed person's
body he says that he sawed off his arm
during a psychotic episode 17 years ago
and had been off his medication at the
time of the episode he said I severed my
arm with a in my hand with a skill saw
the state of my mind was a psychotic
episode to which I say dude it's called
acting like whoa that seems like a
really extreme way to get a job and but
I mean I guess I'm burdens on you Daniel
day-lewis your move Daniel day-lewis my
goodness wow he said that he he
apologized for um he apologized for his
stolen valor because he then claimed
that he was a military vet but that's
that's not good stuff guys you know
treated treating mental illness as
though it is nothing it's not a big
problem is a large large mistake in
virtually every in virtually every
circumstance okay so we will be back
here on Monday in preparation for the
election because it is coming it is
nearly here we are in the final
countdown doo doo doo okay so we will be
back here on Monday with all that have a
good weekend try to enjoy yourself try
to stay off Twitter and I will see you
back here with all the latest news i'm
ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018